this age right now that we're living in
is insane elon is literally providing
real customer service to people over
twitter yeah i mean you saw he ratioed
the president last night yeah i wasn't
gonna go there but he did it bad but i
like it was like it was like a 5x ratio
too it wasn't like i barely beat you
yeah
i like how he like actively responds to
people though people are like hey like i
like this about the tesla's i don't like
this or whatever it is uh he's like
noted like got it like we're gonna bring
that up actually and that's like real
customer feedback that i don't think a
lot of other companies get because
they're reading you know google reviews
yelp whatever yeah i mean there's
obviously some uh real-time aspect to it
and i think people just enjoy his
interactions because they're like damn
this dude's busy as hell he's running
all these different companies he's
trying to make us live on mars he's out
here answering twitter questions about
the navigation system on the tesla yeah
right and if we're gonna get up he's
like swipe up this way press this button
and you should be good but i actually
read i forget who wrote it but there was
an interesting article the other day
that essentially they were just making
the argument they're like no one's gonna
beat tesla because elon's actually the
most gifted engineer of all time they're
like yeah sure they have a big market
position and a big lead and people they
found product market fit and people like
it and they they have the ai and all
these different things okay here it is
starlink here thanks elon musk yeah look
at that just dropped off in what looks
like an army that was like a day right
yeah you are most welcome
robot answer
yeah he's just like you're welcome uh
but but to that point like he's
obviously gifted but he cares about it
too and he's obviously trying to do
things that are extremely difficult so i
think there's some level of respect that
people give him because uh doing things
like trying to uh
form
uh the ability to live on another planet
trying to form ai trying to do these
electronic fields and all these other
things are difficult and uh you have to
respect someone that's not only
attempting one of these but attempting
multiple at the same time uh funding
them in in a variety of ways and and
really interacting with his community in
the same way yeah he here was the the
troll job uh
go to the first one matt yeah so so
biden tweeted president biden tweeted
last night he said ford is investing 11
billion dollars to build electric
vehicles creating 11 000 jobs across the
country gm is making the largest
investment in its history seven billion
dollars to build electric vehicles
creating four thousand jobs in michigan
and then eli comes in he says hey
i don't know if you know but tesla is
the largest ev manufacturer in the world
and we're actually a us-based company he
said tesla has created over 50 000 u.s
jobs building electric vehicles and is
investing more than double gm and
forward combined fyi to the person
controlling this twitter
absolute great troll by yeah just just
he's like i know you didn't tweet that
so no worries oh yeah i don't think
anyone actually thinks
president biden went and tweeted that
and uh uh but it was just funny because
it's true right there's obviously been
history of president biden unwilling to
say the word tesla and mention tesla and
he specifically talks about ford and gm
and other legacy american-made companies
but ultimately look
there's no one providing more ev jobs in
america than tesla there's no one
investing more money in america when it
comes to evs than tesla so ultimately
you can't just keep ignoring the one
company that's in your backyard because
they're not part of your your plans or
all these other things your narrative
yeah i i i think elon at this point is
just a little fed up with it and he's
obviously having some fun on twitter he
knows that his audience is gonna love it
right hundreds of thousands of people
are liking the tweet uh he he he's
responding to the president of the
united states so there's some good fun
with it i don't think he he hates biden
right i think that he's just saying hey
look don't forget about us we're the big
player when it comes to the space we're
providing a lot of jobs we're investing
a lot of money stop ignoring i start
saying the name all these things and i'm
not sure if there's a good reason why
president biden hasn't continued to say
i know he's mentioned it maybe one at
least once maybe one other time after
that but he continues to leave them out
when it comes to important comments like
that right when it comes to jobs and
investments ford and ford and gm aren't
doing even nearly what tesla is doing so
uh it's obviously interesting to see
uh
elon trolling people on twitter let's
not forget they hold almost two billion
dollars worth of bitcoin on their
balance sheets still that was uh at the
end of last year true and people don't
forget that the one time they sold they
did it to make make a profit there no
they did it yeah they literally did it
either tesla could beat earnings and
make a profit uh that's a conspiracy
theory but i think it's true i think
it's true
it's facts until proven otherwise
hey just look at the numbers numbers
don't lie i think that that's true if
they didn't sell they wouldn't beat
earnings if they sold it which they did
they beat earnings i'm not saying it's
important but it's important hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time